[Applause]
Tylar Crispin and Angela Romans have
officially moved in together she's
really hot though this time not in the
Big Brother house I never felt like that
was Rehman's shared this snap to
Instagram breaking the news after an
eventful week in Vegas we are finally
back in our home in LA what was mine is
now ours spoiler alert
he's moving in the big brother runner-up
gushed over his ladylove to ET after the
show ended and you're walking away with
more than a check a couple checks you're
walking away with a girlfriend and we
all got to watch you guys exchange your
first I love yous first kiss is that
weird to know that everybody saw that my
best girl of my dreams man I can't
contain myself like oh are you moving
out here I heard her tell some people
that uh
maybe she's got some room in her house
she could move in she's got some room
and that's the plan I'm moving out here
for sure I can't stay away I cannot stay
away from her
No so is she she's the one I think so I
never felt like that everybody stole I
can't believe yeah yeah you just got out
of that house right there
trapped in there almost 100 days and now
you're out here and people are talking
about all this business that you were
probably just thinking this is just us
right now I don't know what's going on
man like this is sensory overload I
don't know dude like whatever life has
in store for me I'm ready for it well
this is crazy what's the first thing
you're gonna do when they let you out
those doors tonight oh go hang out with
Angela because I got separation anxiety
ra it's been like a week and I'm already
over it have you guys been able to kiss
yet yeah okay on TV again
giving the people what they want
apparently okay it's so awkward visit I
know this is these are uncomfortable
questions to be asked so Angela at the
beginning of the game she laid low a lot
do you know what the fans called her at
home was it colored so furniture because
she was the she was really a character
on the show until it was jury time so
she they called her IKEA furniture yeah
hey she's got fourth place she was a
power player but she had a chill on it
for a bit I get it whatever color I get
to know you got 75 grand a girl I'm
gonna let you out there in the real
world would you come back and play again
are you need some time away I need some
time but I love this game I would do it
again absolutely I love this game I
cannot be happier with the outcome I
could have won but whatever like I would
definitely do it it was close you're
still a winner though I'm a winner like
Casey deserves
Casey deserves it like she got the jury
votes
Casey deserves the win I always say it
whoever won deserved it because somehow
they got it